no show joe biden has been in office 43
days still has not held
a single press conference since becoming
president setting the
modern record among u.s presidents and
get this earlier tonight
during what was a virtual event with
house democrats biden actually said
i guess i'm ready to take some questions
and then well this happened take a look
so i want to thank you all i really mean
it from the bot i want to thank you
thank you thank you thank you and i'm
happy to take questions if that's
what i'm supposed to do nance whatever
you want me to do
you can't make bars and tone you can't
make it up
so what message does biden's absence
send to
foreign leaders do they see what i've
been saying
i see a different joe biden from even
four years ago or
biden debating paul ryan eight years ago
what message does it send to our allies
what about our enemies there are a lot
of them what about our geopolitical foes
because remember
as we learned last week kamala harris
now reportedly taking the
lead on holding all the one-on-one calls
with foreign heads of state
raising even more questions about joe
biden's ability to
carry out his duties and
responsibilities as commander-in-chief
one report today saying
he likes to get to bed and up to the
residents get ready for bed at 7 00 pm
he's missing my show every night that
that is unacceptable
here with reaction former secretary of
state now hudson
institute fellow mike pompeo i loved
your speech by the way
when you when you were talking in your
speech at cpac and you say
yeah the iranians hate my guts pretty
much and yeah the chinese they don't
particularly like me
either i'm like okay i kind of i like
mike even more than i do before
if he has all the right enemies
apparently
sean thanks thanks for having me on the
show tonight yes the iranians the
chinese and the new york times
a long list of people who didn't think
much of america first foreign policy
that
i led under president trump's direction
that's okay and we took good care of
america and i watch what
this administration appears to be doing
it looks like a blame america first
pattern that's already begun to take
place a few things
are really scaring me i want to talk
about very specific examples but first
and and feel free to disagree with me
the biden i see today
compared to four years ago compared to
eight years ago
i see a very different person i see
somebody i would describe as weak frail
and as i've been saying getting
criticized in the media
as struggling cognitively not a medical
diagnosis he just
he gets lost a lot so my question is
if i'm right to foreign leaders like
hostile actors like putin hostile
regimes in russia
hostile regimes in iran china north
korea
mueller's in iran president xi kim
jong-un
are these people that study the u.s
president
looking for potential weakness is there
a possible vulnerability here or am i
way off track
sean world leaders uh and my
counterparts all across the world are
watching very
closely senior leadership all across the
world they watch every statement that is
made they watch every move
they see what their patterns are like
the kinds of behaviors they exhib
exhibit when when times are tough and
when the pressure is really on
and so you remember president trump
would be out there he he talked to the
media all the time probably more than
any modern president he was out
engaging with the media on a broad range
of topics wide open he'd take questions
from
just about everyone when a leader can't
do that when they can't
take questions when they can't explain
the policies that they're engaged in
when they
seem to be hiding behind whether that's
a staff or just the fact that
they don't have time leaders watch that
they wonder and you'll see you'll see
when
the united states exhibits weakness it
creates real risk for our soldiers
sailors airmen and marines all across
the world
weakness begets wars and strength
determines whether an adversary is going
to be deterred and it also determines
whether allies
really want to toss in with us when
times get most difficult
see i believe foreign leaders saw donald
trump as somebody that if he said it he
meant it and
they believed they believed he would do
it
i have no doubt i really believe that's
how i would have interpreted things
interpreted things why would the biden
administration be pressuring
south korea to give the iranian muellers
seven billion dollars and can you
explain
of the big four russia china
geopolitical foes iran north korea
who do we have to worry about the most
well sean as for the money that this
administration wants to hand to the
iranians this is pattern and practice
from what the obama
team did for the eight years they were
in power they viewed the iranians as our
friends
and the gulf states and the israelis as
our enemies this is dangerous for the
united states of america
as for the greatest threat there's no
doubt it is the chinese communist party
they present the most sustained
threat to our fundamental way of life
here in the united states of america i
hope this administration
will take that threat most seriously the
american people deserve it and i know
that they're going to demand it
if let's say there's a scenario donald
trump makes a decision
he's not going to run in 2024 would you
consider getting in that race
i'm always up for a good fight i care
deeply about america you know i've been
part of the conservative movement for an
awfully long time now
i aim to keep at it all right i'll take
that as a
strong maybe i don't know how to
interpret that that's perfect
all right mr secretary thank you for
being with us